>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> All right, everyone.
I think we're going
to get started, here.
To make sure we fit this
into your lunch hour.
Welcome to the Pickford Auditorium.
I'm Rob Casper.
I'm the head of the Poetry
and Literature Center here
at the Library, and I'm delighted
to welcome you to the second
of our Making the Case series with
The National Book Critics Circle.
Before we begin, let me ask you
to turn off your cell phones
and any other electronic
devices that you might have
that will interfere with the event.
And let me tell you a little bit
about the Poetry and
Literature Center.
We're home to the Poet Laureate
Consultant in Poetry and we put
on literary readings,
lectures and panels
of all sorts throughout the year.
If you'd like to find out more about
events like this, you can just go
to that table outside, and
sign the sign-up sheet.
You can also visit us at our
website, www.loc.gov/poetry.
In an ongoing effort to learn
more about our marketing
and communication outreach
as well as continue
to provide the highest
quality program and events,
we would appreciate if you
would evaluate this event.
So, there are some
evaluation sheets.
I'll remind you at the end.
Please take one, fill it out.
You can leave it on this table,
leave it outside, or give it to me.
We really want to know what
you think and what we can do
to improve our programming here
at The Library of Congress.
The mission of The Poetry and
Literature Center is to "Foster
and enhance the public's
appreciation of literature",
and I can't imagine a
better partner in that work
than The National Book
Critics Circle.
The NBCC honors outstanding writing
and fosters a national conversation
about reading, criticism
and literature.
The National Book Critics Circle
Awards are given each March.
They just had their new
awards a couple of months ago,
and they honor the best literature
published in the United States
in six categories;
autobiography, biography, criticism,
fiction, non-fiction and poetry.
These are the only national
literary awards chosen
by critics, themselves.
To find out more about
the organization,
you can visit their
website, www.bookcritics.org.
Last fall, critic and
scholar, Steven Burke,
helped us to launch this series
with a poetry-focused lecture
titled, "The Poem is You".
I am thrilled and delighted today
to introduce Elizabeth Taylor
to provide us with a
complimentary lecture on fiction.
Her lecture titled, "American
Fiction: Connecting the Dots",
will help us get a sweeping
sense of where the art is at,
from a critic who served
both as president
and as a board member of the NBCC.
After her lecture, we'll have a
brief Q and A session as well,
and we have a mic, when you come
over and just get you miked,
so we can capture what
you say for our webcast.
And note that this event
is being videotaped
for a future webcast at The Library.
And by participating in the Q
and A, you give us permission
for the future use
of that recording.
Now, please join me in
welcoming Elizabeth Taylor.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much for being here.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks so much to The Library
of Congress for inviting me
for this incredible
initiative to bring books
and reading to the world.
So, and I'm honored to be here
to talk about being a critic
in the world of literature.
And it's just a very
rewarding kind of job to have.
So, let me just say, a
friend of mine had gone
on the United Airlines website.
This was just a few days ago,
to check her flight for Paris.
And she'd forgotten her password.
And, to reset it, she was asked to
answer some questions and then, so,
she, of course, the question
was, what are you reading?
And she, of course, chose that.
So, here's what she found.
This was the list.
So, anybody notice a word
missing from this list?
[Crowd replying] No fiction!
Where's fiction?
There's, you know, historical.
There's magazines.
There's mystery.
But, there's just.
There's professional development.
But no fiction.
So, it doesn't even make the list.
So, I started thinking, how
long has it been this way,
that we sort of think of fiction
as the sort of, the sideshow?
What's going on?
So, of course, I looked to the past.
And to the great Robert Penn Warren.
He was a native Kentuckian.
He won three Pulitzer prizes.
His first was in 1947 for the
astonishing, now classic novel
about American politics,
"All the King's Men".
So, in 1966, May 10th, like almost
to the day fifty years
ago, we're here.
Warren spoke at the Plaza
Hotel to a huge audience.
And there weren't attendance
records.
But there's, I saw the pictures,
so I could discern who was there.
So, it was a grainy black
and white photograph.
And I could discern
a few famous faces.
There was Barbara Tuckman, I saw
Rose Kennedy, Robert F. Kennedy.
That was, like, how important this
literature was, that, you know,
that these people were there.
So, Warren began his talk
by saying, the only trend
of the novel is, we're
told toward death.
That's reassuring, right?
He said, it's been declared dead
in the 1920's before "The Sound
and the Fury" and "Finnegan's Wake".
He said, even D.H.
Lawrence had said,
it...D.H. Lawrence
actually wrote this.
It becomes harder and harder to
read the whole of any modern novel.
One reads a bit and knows the rest,
or one doesn't want to know more.
That's, but Warren admitted, too,
that he occasionally sentiment.
So, he told the group at the Plaza.
I'm 1960, I admit, I'm
bored by a good many novels.
Bored by the some that stand high
on the bestseller list,
in critical esteem.
And this makes me feel
out of step with the march
of civilization and chit chat.
But there are other novels, he said,
also some on the bestseller
list, that do not bore me.
In fact, compel and fascinate me.
And, it's hard to put
these fascinating novels
in a single package marked "trend".
The trouble with, is that
a good novel is apt to rear
up on its hind legs and
shout, "Leave me alone!
If you call me a trend again,
I'll spit in your eye".
So, in this, kind of world where
words are flying off screens
and devices and there are more and
more works of fiction published,
you know, it's amazing, you know,
to think that, how hard it is
to find really good books.
And, estimates vary
widely about sort
of how many books are
published, it's a,
vary from works of
fiction, actually.
From 250,000 to 2 million.
I mean, there's just, it's
really hard to discern.
And paradoxically, I'll note
that, with the demise of newspaper
and book sections, you won't
hear about a lot of these books.
But, let me try to explain how I,
as a critic, experience that volume.
As the chair of the fiction
jury of The Pulitzer Prizes,
we receive boxes and boxes of books.
Over 300 works of fiction a year.
And that's just a small fraction,
considering that there's
an entry fee,
and many people just don't submit.
Most of them don't submit.
At The Tribune, where I worked
and ran the book section
for fifteen years, I received 200
books a day, in the tiny book room.
So, to reduce the number,
I have asked publishers
to send them to me at home.
And, so, what does
that mean for a critic?
So, this is just a sample day.
So, this is what comes
for me in a day.
That's like, I just sorted
out, like the fiction.
So, that's like, a lot.
And so, the question
that people of us
on The National Book Critics
Circle board is that a huge part
of what we do isn't just writing.
It's about discovery.
It's like, what's in
those boxes and envelopes.
You know, and, my excitement over
what's in them is really, it is a,
it exceeds my aggravation
about the falling over,
the piles in my living room.
And that, I believe, that part is
just not, people just don't think
about when they think
about being a critic.
So, it's being about an engaged
critic, attuned to what's
on the page and the
world that reflects,
and from which it has emerged.
What's worthy of our
attention, and that is, I think,
the question to think about.
So, over the years, I've sort
of acquired a critical gene.
And this critical gene informs,
actually, how I see the world.
About, it's about living and
reading and thinking actively,
and not only about literature.
But also, sort of, by being
simultaneously less judgmental,
but with stronger convictions.
Part of the work we do is trying
to understand the landscape
and not be a slave to it.
A little mini case study.
Huge admirer, everyone's
probably read the novel,
"Purity", but Jonathan Franzen.
I'm sure, anyway.
For about, he was on the
cover of Time Magazine.
Not many novelists are.
And, newspapers, magazines
across the country.
It all felt compelled to weigh in.
This was a big, serious novel.
But that meant that reviews and
essays were not going to other works
of fiction, that, you know, that
wonderful, wonderful works that,
they just didn't ever,
weren't published
because of the Franzomania.
And, in fact, if you read, as I did,
like, most of the reviews, like,
from everybody from the, you
know, newspaper in Tennessee,
to Washington State and
even internationally.
The reviews kind of
sounded like, the same.
So, like, why do we need all
those reviews of the same book
when we could be like, really
discovering a new voice?
Now, that is I will
note, a minority view.
This is what book critics
argue about all the time.
But, then, we do argue about
everything all the time.
But being a critic is
about making choices.
And I think it's important.
There's another statistic, again,
these, you know, statistics, are.
Just have to take them
with a grain of salt.
But, that the only stand-alone
book section in the country,
the New York Times, said
to reviews, only 1 percent
of the books published in America.
That's really small.
There's so many books that, you
know, it's hard to hear about.
But the secret truth of being a
critic is that we all love the hunt.
And the sense of discovery.
We want that super
tingle of excitement.
We want to find that new voice.
At the same time, because a
critic, we have to see things
from the counterintuitive
thing, I mean,
I worry about this bias
against older writers.
About, sort of, maybe writers
whose first two books didn't really
pan out.
So, they had to go to
a really small press.
And maybe a writer who's they just
write, while they have a day job.
Ten hours, they're raising
their children, whatever.
And they don't have a part
in the literary community.
And I think it's really important
to try to refine them, too.
And resist that impulse to
find the next pretty new thing.
This, so. Literary prizes,
I think, can help that.
I think, as a judge, I mean, I sort
of try to sort out the pedigree
of a book and really respond
to what's on the page.
I think that, and through fiction,
you can really see, it's kind of a
through line of American concerns.
As we're looking to find
magical books, there are,
despite what Warren said
about themes, some do merge.
So, keep thinking of this.
At The Library of Congress, I
came across Louis Untermeyer.
Does anybody remember him,
the Poetry Collections
from our childhood?
And he was appointed the
fourteenth consultant to poetry
at The Library of Congress.
So, but the year, and this
was in 1961, but in 1960,
he chaired the Fiction Jury
for the Pulitzer Prizes.
I think prizes are important because
they can get people's attention.
Can, you know, people
see those [inaudible]
of a national book
critic circle prize
and essentially saying, read this.
And there's so many books to
read, that's what prizes can do.
So, in his report on the
Pulitzer Prizes, Untermeyer,
this was in 1960, he found
that, for the American novel,
1960 was disappointing in the
performance of established writers.
Gratifying in the achievements
of younger ones.
He charged that William Styron
and John Updike had failed to live
up to their early promise.
And that James Michener
and John O'Hara,
he grappled with larger themes.
But, "Their reach generally
exceeded their grasp".
But Untermeyer praised what he
called the string of new talent,
which constantly revitalizes
American fiction.
In what may go down as the best
literary backhand compliment
in history, he wrote of the
winner that, "The achievement,
it seems to us, may
be gaged by the fact
that her story embraces virtually
all the clichés of a southern novel,
they're nevertheless made to
appear here as fresh and original.
Clichés? So, he was, of course,
talking about "To Kill
a Mockingbird".
It's amazing.
Full of clichés.
So, but this was actually a sort
of a pivotal point
for American fiction.
That this novel was recognized.
That was written.
The legacy of slavery
has haunted that novel,
and it actually shaped much
literature over the generations.
And this kind of became clear
to me, Warren's comments aside,
this trend became evident in the
New York Times Book Review Survey 25
years ago.
No wait, actually,
only a decade ago.
That sought to identify the
opinions of the "Single Best Work
of American Fiction Published
over the Last 25 Years."
So, you can imagine, like,
people talking about this.
What is meant by published?
What is best?
What is American?
You know, just, was all sort of.
But, interesting, the best book
they landed on was "Beloved".
It was sort of interesting
to see the line from
"To Kill a Mockingbird"
to "Beloved".
You know, it was a stab in the
heart, an agonizing remembrance
of a former slave in post-war Ohio.
But it did what great novels do.
Blended sort of private
destinies into public events
and it infused the story of a
family trauma, repression of memory,
themes that we still see now
and had mythic dimensions
and an otherworldliness.
But, interesting, just an
aside about the prizes,
critically acclaimed, but failed
to win the National Book Award
or The National Book
Critics Circle Prize.
In fact, the National Book Award,
the winner was a book that,
probably a very nice book, but
nobody can remember or heard of,
"Paco's Story", about
the Vietnam War.
So, after she failed to win these
prizes, 48 African American writers,
or black writers, as
they were described then,
protested in open letters
to the New York Times.
It was really rallied and
they expressed their passion
for "Beloved".
It went on to win The
Pulitzer Prize.
And it's interesting to
see that through line.
So, Jane Smiley, thinking
about sort of "Beloved",
is a wonderful writer
and a critic, herself.
I trust you've read her.
And she has written a, "Beloved"
seemed to have the historical scope
of a best or most important
novel would have.
And that, what the
most important thing
over the last 25 years
was the rethinking
and rewriting of American history.
It's interesting, that she
slightly even looked further back.
She said Smiley was struck in
the formal contrast between
"Beloved" and "Uncle Tom's Cabin".
They take up a really difficult
subject, but, as Smiley said,
still uses melodrama and polemic,
the novels straightforward,
suspenseful and infuriating
because she is furious.
But Morrison is much cannier.
She uses the form of a ghost story,
and it fills in with folk tales.
Of course, that's what Morrison
wanted to do, Smiley says.
To rewrite history to tell
the story of a truer way
than had ever been told before.
And Smiley, herself, is sort
of brilliant about how history,
memory and history
mutate into fiction.
As you may know, remember,
she wrote "The Thousand Acres"
which was a reimagination
of American farmland
through the lens of King Lear.
So, this idea of history
kind of mutating through,
and race is really important,
but there are some
other dimensions, also.
And that is, the spirit,
the immigrant experience is,
has sort of infused the imagination
of a new generation of writers.
It used to be that immigration
novels were all about, sort of,
you know, sort of Marjorie
Morningstar-ish kind
of getting acclimated and
accultured to assimilation,
but these are sort of,
almost anti-assimilation.
Resistant to the idea
of assimilation.
And I was, I was really happy
to be pleased to chair the jury
that advocated for this next book
that won the Pulitzer in 2007,
and I think it's really
important for many reasons.
Have you all read "The Brief
and Wondrous Life of Oscar Wao"?
>> Yes.
>> Isn't it a great book?
A really great book.
So, it's, it's just such a
reminder of how the American sort
of immigration novel has just
been sort of updated and made hip.
And then, not assimilation,
acculturation, had sort of morphed
into a sort of uneasiness.
And that, that sense that
immigrants are stranded
between where they've been and where
they're going and they're sort of,
in sort of a no-place land
with no real allegiance.
And that is a theme we'll see in
a log of immigrant literature.
And also, in substance,
but also style matters.
And style matters particularly
when it's central to the story.
When it becomes so
essential to the telling that,
you couldn't imagine
the story without it.
And these novels are
revolutionary in form.
And three years after Junot
Diaz, and he, Junot Diaz borrows
from science fiction, you
know, a New Jersey teenager,
so there's science fiction elements.
He also is playing with structure.
But in this book.
Jennifer Egan, "A Visit
from the Goon Squad"...
>> It's a great one.
>> Isn't it?
Oh, love it.
We have the same taste!
So, it's just, it's
just a dazzling book.
And it's won the Pulitzer and
the National Book Critics Prize.
It's full of heart and
complex characters.
And in many ways, it's an
old fashioned social novel.
But, it's brilliantly
and unusually structured.
It's structured like an album,
but, I guess we're supposed to say
like a digital download now.
I mean, but.
So, it's begin with any
chapter of the novel.
Or you can shuffle the chapters.
And each, like, song
fits into the album.
The chapters fit together.
There's no beginning, no end.
It's a beautiful loop with all
these characters intersecting.
And it's also, in many
ways, it's about one of the,
it's about technology
and how we respond to it.
So, it's, and I actually wrote
this a while ago, I prefer people
who don't quote themselves,
but, what can I say?
It was, I described it in the proof
polls as an inventive interrogation
of growing up and growing
old in the digital age.
And it displays big
hearted curiosity
about cultural change at warp speed.
So, just, as you may
recall, you know,
and this was written five years ago.
Think of like, when she wrote this.
Her baby shopping with
hand-held devices.
That sounded weird.
But now, we kind of see
that it could happen.
And so, it's, we can see this
sort of trend of technology.
And it sort of, the dramas are, that
used to be kind of isolated mystery,
science fiction, are
all kind of going away.
And one of the geniuses
of the Jennifer Egan book is she has
one character, one chapter, rather,
in a PowerPoint presentation.
Which is amazing.
So, an example of how novels and
fiction are defined kind of a genre,
and they're kind of mashing them up
and making something
new, there's a new novel.
And this one, just a few weeks
ago, won the Pulitzer Prize.
Oh, all right, good.
But wait. Let me go back.
That is the, from the
PowerPoint from Jennifer Egan's
"Visit from the Goon Squad".
You see how it's just like,
this is just one chapter.
It doesn't overwhelm it.
But it's, it's just a really
funny, fun way to tell it.
So, "The Sympathizer".
So, this just won the
Pulitzer Prize.
Now, have you read that?
Okay, well.
I'm two for three.
So, it's again.
On first reading, it's sort
of a complex immigration tale
with this wonderful voice.
It's not unlike Junot Diaz in that
the narrator's wry and professional.
The guy is a man who
lives a divided life.
But stylistically,
"Sympathizer" does something else.
Genres are merging.
It's science fiction, spy story,
it's an old fashioned spy
story about, you know,
communist Vietnam,
divided loyalties.
So, it's interesting.
We go back to, sort of,
"Paco's Story", you know,
won that National Book Award
instead of "Beloved", and so we see.
But the, here we are,
still with Vietnam.
It's still this persistent
idea in fiction.
And it's, this is just a, it's
like an old fashioned spy novel.
And it's this hybrid, "Sympathizer".
It's a really beguiling book.
And, but I want to return to a
little bit of an earlier idea.
Which, is like the idea of
a critic in all of this.
And the act of discovery and
the importance of being part
of a kind of, what I
think of as a flourishing
and robust sort of
literary eco system.
And it exists beyond book stores,
book reviews and writing books.
So, when Diaz and Egan landed
at my door, I was really,
I had been reading
their short stories.
They had been in The New Yorker.
They had previous books.
But, it, when "The Sympathizer"
came out, I mean, here is,
he was a professor of
English and American Studies
in Diversity Studies at
University of Southern California.
And he had written an academic
book in 2002, "Race and Resistance,
Literature and Politics
in Asian America".
It's published by Oxford
University Press.
But, you know, a novel.
This, kind of, hit
people like a surprise.
So, it really dealt.
This was real act discovery.
But he didn't just
come out of the blue.
I mean, people, we think, people
really are working at this.
And so, about five
years ago, actually,
I called him because he had
submitted a story to something
that I'm involved with, the
Nelson Algren Short Story Contest.
And this is what I think was
the great kind of eco system.
That this contest really
supported this guy
as he is aspiring to
be a fiction writer.
So, this contest was
founded in 1983.
And by a couple that
really liked fiction.
And they, among the earliest
winners, Stuart Dybeck,
and Lise Erdrich is
to win the big Library
of Congress Prize, right, very soon.
She astonishing.
Judges were, have been Eudora
Welty, Jane Smiley, Chang Rae Lee,
Alexander Hammond are
two authors who sort
of updated this immigrant theme.
Anyway, the contest
is entirely blind.
No entry fee, no barred entry.
Stories are all numbered.
We don't know whether, you know, if
they come from a city like Iowa City
or Brooklyn, which were the
big hot houses for fiction.
Doesn't ma...you know,
we don't know.
So, 3500 stories.
Four rounds of judges.
And so, this is an example.
I think it's kind of rare.
Where quality really does rise.
It wasn't just a walk.
And this, he was a winner of
the Nelson Algren Prize, so,
I have been, like, tracking him.
But he, and it also gave him a
little bit of financial support.
It gave him a publication in
one of his first publication,
published works of fiction.
And I, I think it's just so
important to have these sort
of smaller places that will support
writers and be part of the sort
of the ground level, so
that writers can flourish.
And I also mention this, to
provide, you know, we can help,
it's a perspective on these writers.
We don't just, like, all of a sudden
open a box, and there's a book.
We can, it's part of something.
And I think as a critic
it's important
to understand what,
where a book comes from.
And but over time, I've come
to believe that it's not only
about sort of what's on the page
that matters, and what we write
as critics in the books we select.
Those are to write about
and our approaches.
That really is important.
But I've also come to see that,
I think that a critic's job
is also to be an activist.
Not to be a champion or be
boosterish about particular books,
and not like to ride a hobby horse
of your best friend who, you know,
wrote that self-published novel.
But, although, I wouldn't
have a best friend
who wrote a self-published novel.
But, rather, think of ways to get
people into books in libraries.
You know, to get people
to pick up books to read.
And you know, so, with fewer
places to find books, and peoples,
I encourage everybody to sort of
do what they can, like a friend
and I have been bemoaning the
state of book reviews for years.
And they've just been dwindling.
At one point, there was a
campaign to save book reviews.
So, we despaired the
evaporation of this way
to get the public into books.
And we wanted to improvise and
kind of propel the conversation.
So we just decided,
and this is possible.
This is what tech,
how technology helps.
We just decided to start a
book review, and we called it,
The National Book Review.
So, instead of just decrying
online world, we just embraced it.
And we want to give new
writers who are looking
to express themselves
an opportunity.
So, I want to say that
criticism is a very public act.
In that it's essential and it's
this discovery and this kind of,
the way we push books out in,
books worthy, worthy books,
into the public, is important.
Because, fiction is
the radar picking
up what's happening in the world.
And helps us sort of
understand how we feel
about what we don't yet know.
Fiction helps readers look
behind and beyond the headlines.
It makes us feel empathy.
It challenges us to go places
that we might not go alone.
It's like a lightbulb
and the world's dark.
It's an emotional GPS.
It lets us go on these uncharted
roads and yet feel safe.
And fiction also can imagine a
world that doesn't yet exist.
And because, in the end,
that's what we have.
Our convictions, and we
have our imaginations.
And before I close, I
just want to sort of,
last nod to the amazing Robert
Penn-Warren, who, again,
50 years ago, to, this,
almost to the day, he said,
"The novel may even
leave the printed page,
but it could still be a novel."
So, there's hope.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thanks for that, Elizabeth.
And I'm wondering if you
have any questions you'd
like to ask our critic today?
>> Such a small room,
I'm Shelly Meyers.
>> Hi.
>> Retired, thankfully,
so I can read much more.
>> Good.
>> And I've been reading for
many, many years very voraciously.
And I just am, I'm curious.
One of the reasons I'm here today.
I was particularly interested.
And I'm glad to hear that you
believe that this is a good novel.
Because, I always go right to the
Pulitzers of the year and read them.
I have for the last fifty
years, for heaven's sakes.
But the Goldfinch and "All the
Light You Cannot See" and many other
of the popular literature in the
last three or two or three years,
perhaps, I found so disappointing.
Terribly disappointing.
And, I just wonder if
you think, as a society,
we've become less demanding
of our fiction writers?
And so, I am tending now, to stay
away from the popular literature
and go to old books, and science
fiction books and memoirs,
because the popular literature is,
I just find it not substantive.
Not daring.
Not moving, if you.
I just, it's sort of
a social commentary.
>> No, it is an interesting, I mean,
our, I mean, do prizes always go
to the books that should?
Of course, I'm a little partial
to "All the Light We Cannot See"
because I did chair
the committee for that.
But I do think it's, we'll
have to talk about it later.
>> Is there literature
in that period
of history, is my point about that.
>> Right. No, no, no, no.
There's a lot.
Yeah. I love the.
I actually.
I felt that, structurally,
it was like a prose.
It was a set of prose poems.
But, I, I liked it structurally.
I thought it kind of worked.
But, I can, yes.
But there, the thing is, about
awards and, I don't, is that they're
so many amazing, worthy books.
There, we try to do, I mean,
for me, the question is, do.
I say to the committee I'm on, like,
will this book withstand
the test of time?
Will this book, you
know, last 50 years?
So, I don't, yeah.
But I'm, popular opinion,
it's tough.
I mean, sometimes, I
think critics often tend
to do the, sort of the reverse.
And dismiss a book because
the public likes it.
I mean, that's more of a fear
of mine, that we'll say, "Wow,
if it's too popular, you
know, what do people know?"
Which, makes me despair.
But, there are really
you know, worthy books.
Prizes help.
But they can't be the only thing.
So, I'd say, also, when it
doubt, look at the finalists.
They matter, too.
No.
>> And I do.
>> Right, you know, so, you know.
I mean, you know.
Yeah. And also, I'm also tilting.
I should say, I've tilted
very American this talk.
Because, because, I
want to overlook that.
That it, sort of diversity,
international voices,
is just astonishing.
I mean, Marlon James is astonishing.
Americana is a fantastic novel.
And I'm involved with another
set of prizes that's all about,
it's called the Heartland Prize.
But I think of the Heartland
as a metaphorical place.
So, you can think about, I
think she really redefines the
immigrant story.
So, I hear you on the prizes.
But...
>> Something else, it's
not just the prizes.
There's a lot else out there.
A lot of other things.
Like [inaudible] new
book and, I mean,
a lot of the literature
just don't seem.
I don't know whether it's society
or me or [inaudible] fiction, or...
>> Well, well.
But I think, and I think that
how do you hear about books?
>> I do a lot of just,
I just do my research.
I read all the reviews
and I have friends and...
>> Right.
>> And I do a lot of research
before I read, because there's
so much I want to read...
>> Right, so, like, I think
that it's, it's, it's hard.
Because, even when we
research, I mean, you know,
just through a simple
Google, it won't show.
It'll show you the
most popular books.
It's really hard to do that deep
digging around to find that sort of,
what's about to pop
up and what hasn't,
you know, hasn't gotten lucky.
I mean, that's what I was
trying to say about the Franzen.
And, I actually liked "Purity"
as a book, more than most people.
But, I felt like it
took a lot of air time.
You know. So, like, those, that was
like, you know, a good six weeks
of books that you weren't
hearing about.
I think.
>> You mentioned a couple of things
about the timelessness of the books
and the context of books.
But what do you really look
for when you read a novel?
>> So, I look for,
it's a great question.
And I'm always changing my mind.
I'll, so, because every book has
a different sort of calibration.
I look for something
that feels special.
What's special?
I like, I personally like
a novel with a great voice.
I personally privilege, I privilege
a messy, big, social novel.
Rather than a sort of pristine,
carefully constructed sort
of compact littler novel.
Yet, so, I work through that
to try to respect both and try
to judge them against each other.
But, so, voice.
I think language really matters.
I, even those big messy
social novels, I like the,
I like to be really
beautifully written.
I want to be surprised by how the
sentences get together and how they,
the imagery that comes off the page.
And I, more than probably, many of
my critics who are probably smarter
than I, like, I go for
a novel with heart.
I, you know, I don't like.
I want a novel to have heart.
I don't want it to be cold.
I don't want it to be sort
of excessively ironic.
And, yeah.
That means.
Is that helpful?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> You spoke about,
I think you said,
you receive about 300 books a
year, at the [inaudible] fiction?
>> That was just the fiction, yeah.
>> I was just amazed by that, and I,
I'm surprised that critics are
not always signing, you know?
>> We, we, we are, actually.
But you know.
Yeah. Yeah.
The numbers are staggering.
I mean, and, especially with, you
know, it's like, I did, at one.
I did tell the story
that, I once did a kind
of a round table calling
famous people up and saying,
are serious books in trouble?
And, asked a variety of people.
In fact, one was aforementioned
Jane Smiley.
She's like, serious
books may be in trouble
but really funny books
are in trouble.
It's kind of a good point.
There are not a lot of like comic
novels in the way there were in sort
of the 19th century, or like...
[inaudible].
And then, John Berendt, I remember,
he said he wrote in "Midnight
in the Garden of Good and
Evil", he is very smart.
He said, you know, don't
confuse products with books.
And I was like, there are
a lot of books out there
that are really products.
You know, these series books
that are made by book factories.
I mean, I think there's a
place for James Patterson.
But those are, like, they're like,
they're kind of an
assembly line kind of thing.
Or some of the mystery writers
who do, you know, or genre writers
who do, kind of a formula
every six months
to just kind of feed the beast.
And keep their name out there.
So, I think.
But books, books are, you know.
We're always looking for the books
and to get push away the products.
>> I hear that, of course.
At the National Book Reviews,
are you finding new writers?
>> Yeah. That's, yes, we are.
And it's hard, and I mean.
This is, it's kind of
amusing because, you know,
diversity, you have to work for it.
And it means, like, for the Nelson
Algren Prize, you know, I, you know,
go to sort of not just a traditional
MFA programs, and it's the same
with National Book Review.
But try to get people from sort of
collectives and other places that,
you know, can, are not part of
the book review establishment.
So, we do, that is a priority.
And we try.
>> How do you find the selections?
>> Oh, how do I find them?
Usually, well, first of
all, like, I ask my friends.
And, like, like, a wonderful poet.
Rigoberto Gonzales, is on The
National Book Critics Circle.
It's like he turned me on to a whole
set of, you know, sort of listservs
to find a new group of writers.
So, you have to be.
I mean, I was reported
for fifteen years.
For because, talking a
desk job as an editor.
So, I like sort of digging around
and finding those groups of,
you know, like of, like there's a
fab...I don't know if you remember,
but there's the binders on Facebook.
This is why technology
really can help.
There's Binders of Women Writers.
And the Binders of the [inaudible].
There's like little groups of,
you know, binders of, you know,
short fiction writers, and it's
women but then they sub group
and self-select into smaller groups.
So, I, you kind of have to be
aggressive about finding them.
And I, that, that's how I, I do it.
There's not a sort of science to it.
But once you start finding people,
they lead you to other people.
That's, and, so the kind of web.
And, but, and diversity, it, isn't.
It's always changing.
So, we're where used to be sort of
most you know, about gender, race,
now it's about sort of gender.
It's more about gender.
Used to be just sort of
male-female, now it's about gender
and finding different
groups that are more fluid.
So, really, kind of saying,
what's going on out there?
>> You talked about form
when it comes to fiction,
and was sort of changed with
art, with form in your examples.
Can you talk, I don't, maybe
because I'm not a fiction writer.
I don't think about form
in relation to fiction.
So, can you talk about the value
of form when it comes to fiction,
or changes or sort of in some
way, why it's important to think
about that in relation to fiction.
>> Yeah, well.
I mean, I guess one way to think
of it is, I mean, like, form.
A well, seems really simple
and elementary, as I say it.
A well-formed book
is easier to read.
You know, that, that, it has like a
story, a structure, that may not be.
But the changes in it, for instance.
I should have talked about it more.
But like, flash fiction or and very
short fiction that are almost like,
they're essentially
sort of like prose poems
that are just like one or two pages.
There are, that's and some.
You can be, have a really
well-formed short story.
I should have mentioned this.
One of the greatest
discoveries of the last year
for me was a woman
called Lucia Berlin.
Does anybody remember her?
And she, I can't think
of the title of the book.
But she had been writing
for like 30 years.
She had died and then her
stories were collected.
"Manual for Cleaning Women".
That was one of her stories.
That was the title story.
The title of the book and one of
the stories in her collection.
I mean, these stories
were astonishing.
She had just lived on the
marsh and she had, you know,
had been in and out of rehab.
She'd been a cleaning lady.
She had done.
And these stories were
just a knockout.
But they're so well formed.
That's an example of
well-formed story.
So, this, you know, the
sort of it, so, you know,
the structure sort of matters.
But you don't want
to see the stitches?
Do you see what I mean?
Like, you don't want to,
shouldn't be apparent.
That's my thing.
Like, you should be easy.
And it's you know, yeah.
It so, or should be.
Or another thing it parallels, like,
it should be all flying
at the same level.
So.
>> I'm going to agree with you.
I love "All the Light
We Cannot See",
structurally, characters,
everything.
I read it back to back.
Virtually within a week of Kate
Atkinson's "Life After Life".
What did you think of that?
>> I, yeah.
I...
>> I, I absolutely loved it.
Loved it.
>> Many friends of
mine have loved it.
I have not read that.
I read something earlier.
I read her earlier stuff.
I just have not read that one.
But...
>> It's very interesting
structurally.
I think maybe you can see
the seams, or maybe...
>> Yeah, but.
And sometimes...
>> Yeah.
>> The, you need.
Ah, like "Fates and Furies".
You want to see the...she's written
it so that you can see that seam.
That's integral to the story.
>> No doubt.
That was great.
"Fates and Furies".
>> Yes. It was, very.
>> Breathtaking.
>> Absolutely.
It. All right, we agree.
I well...
>> You can...
>> All right.
I know. Whew!
All right.
Yes.
>> [Inaudible]
>> I know.
We all. I mean, I'm.
I'm still you know, that.
At the National Book
Critics Circle, you know,
remember nothing but the grudges.
You know, remember nothing
but the books we disagreed on.
You know, I'm still,
like, you know, I yeah.
I think I was the.
I don't think "Underworld" won.
And I, I'm still upset about it.
You know, I'll bring it up.
Like, you know, the wording
is entirely different.
>> So, you did...
>> I loved it.
>> Me too.
Me too.
>> I loved it.
And I just.
I think, but I think it didn't win.
So, you know.
So.
>> Other questions?
>> Since we're at the Library of
Congress, what role do you think
that libraries can play
in promoting fiction?
>> Great question.
And I'm so.
I mean, I think it is really.
I was tracking at the eco
system and the critics.
I think libraries are just
so important and you know,
you're so lucky to live here
with these flourishing resources.
But so many libraries around the
country are really suffering.
But libraries are important.
I mean, first of all.
One of the great examples
is Ferguson.
You know, that library stayed open.
It was like a refuge.
It was, it was just critical.
In that place.
I think libraries are morphing
now into community centers.
And where people come for the day.
For job hunting.
To hang out.
I think the question is, you know,
people bring their little kids
to the library and the older
people come but the question is how
to get the sort of middle group.
Look, I was actually at a really
great library a few weeks ago.
And they asked, they, this
library, did not just one book
of the, one book one town.
They did "Nobody's Fool", which was
the Rick Russo, Richard Russo book.
And then they did "Everybody's
Fool",
which is the new book that's
coming out in a few weeks.
And so, and they're showing a film
and they're having a
series of discussions.
And they're really trying
to bring people together.
And I think that is a great
example of sort of being inventive
and libraries sort of
reaching new audiences.
I think they are really important.
Especially in cities
that really need it.
Some of the suburban libraries
are really do a great job
and they have beautiful,
beautiful resources.
But other libraries
are really struggle,
Chicago there's a fantastic
public library.
It's great.
And it anchors communities.
And people say that, you know, when
a neighborhood is in transition,
before it, you know, the,
it's really a bad situation.
They'll put in a police
station and put in a library.
And that'll sort of will indicate
that there's going to be stability.
And I think that libraries, you
know, can be really inventive.
One library in Chicago has, like,
the neighborhood library
has, like, an autism room.
So, where, like, people
have resources.
So I think it's really
important for libraries to,
if they have the resources,
to try to offer niches.
My kids and I used to go to a
neighborhood library to play chess.
You know, I think, all those things
are beyond sort of taking out books.
So, you know.
>> On that note...
>> Thank you.
>> I scheduled a visit...
Thank you.
>> Thank you for the talk.
Thanks for coming in.
[applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.